if your kid uses social media for more
than 3 hours a day they're at double or
triple the risk of gain depression or
anxiety and I think the thing that's
really hard for us as parents our kids
are probably going to go through some
Darkness oh my gosh like the term does
not do justice to how hard this is we
are investing everything in the project
that is making these children excellent
and I could see that those who were over
managed were lacking an agenty see
overwhelmingly all they want and all
they need is for us to listen and be
[Music]
empathic I really love being a
dad and it may sound trite but it truly
has been the greatest gift of my
lifetime my kids have been my most
profound teachers and raising them has
been a privilege I don't take lightly
but too often I grade myself in
comparison to others I set myself
against an idealized projection of what
I imagine a perfect dad to be or what I
witness super dads doing on social media
every time I scroll and while I do my
best not to repeat yesterday's mistakes
and also to interrupt all the misguided
patterns that I've inherited that we've
all inherited by past
Generations I still wonder what are my
blind spots and how can I do better how
can I be the best parent I can
be well this is the terrain of today's
investigation my thoughts synthesized
with the most impactful and actionable
advice from the parenting experts the
psychologists and therapists and
Educators and doctors who have graced
the show over the years to provide an
actionable primer on all things mindful
parenting a starting point to begin or
to reignite a lifelong journey to
understand how to be a better parent if
you're a Wrangler of young humans just
trying to make the Right Moves or maybe
you just want to better understand why
kids think and behave the way they do
then this deep dive is appointment
listening as always you can find links
to the full conversations for all those
highlighted along with other useful
resources in the show notes at Rich
roll.com
[Music]
as parents our number one goal more
often than not is to protect our kids we
want to do everything in our power to
set them up for future success to save
them from harm to provide them with
opportunities we didn't have and to
catch them when they fall but as good
intentioned as this behavior is the
reality is that inserting ourselves too
much over time can have lasting
unintentionally negative impacts on our
kids'
lives you know the word for this
helicopter parenting it's easy to fall
into the Trap of believing we're helping
and protecting our children when we're
actually undermining their capacity to
fend for themselves undermining their
ability to develop resilience or a
healthy relationship with failure or
even ownership over the equation between
output and
outome it's hard to accept but some of
the most disappointing times of our
kids' lives are the most important we
need to let them experience
disappointment sadness and even pain so
they can build resilience if we protect
our kids from every negative emotion at
all costs we may be inadvertently
depriving them of some of the most
important experiences of their young
lives former dean of freshman and
undergraduate advising at Stanford
University
as well as the author of The New York
Times bestseller how to raise an adult
Julie ligot heims warns us of the
negative consequences of blocking your
children from distress in all forms
particularly when we don't give them
agency when parents continuously step in
to prevent their children from facing
any hardship or challenge they deny
their children the opportunity to learn
and the opportunity to grow from those
experiences
here's
[Music]
Julie so we've done the thinking for
them the planning for them the
troubleshooting um the fixing the
managing the handling all in furtherance
of these outcomes we think lead to a
successful life and it's almost like we
take our helicopter rotors and we lift
them in the helicopter and arrive them
at the future we have in mind and then
we can say look you've arrived you're
here and then the kid is bewildered at
the place of arrival because they
haven't done the heavy lifting they've
certainly worked hard it's not to say
kids aren't hardworking in this in this
context but they've been so over managed
and overh helped they really are
unfamiliar with their own selves in in
my first book how to raise an adult I
call it existential impotence unfamiliar
with the self we treat our kids like
they're are bonsai trees you know the
Bonsai is such an Exquisite creation of
the gardener The Gardener decides the
direction in which that tree will grow
which branches will be clipped and which
will flourish and the shape of it and um
it's a lovely creation but at the end of
the day it is a possession of the
gardener and something to be oo and ODed
over and people can come to the gardener
and say look what you've done aren't you
amazing and we need them to be glorious
so that we can feel better about
ourselves and it's harmful and it speaks
to an unwellness in our psyche in our SP
Spirit how many of us are devoting
countless hours to chauffeuring
concering helping with the homework
overh helping outright doing the
homework planning and fixing and
managing our kids' lives and we have a
primary partner over there in the wings
and our relationship with that person is
dwindling and diminishing and suffering
cuz we're not watering that plant we're
not giving that relationship attention
the very relationship that might have
created these children you know
languishes because we are investing
everything in the project that is making
these children excellent so that we can
feel that we have you know the right
sort of um accolades to boast about at a
cocktail
party Julie goes on to say that instead
of bonsai trees we should think of our
children as wildflowers
resilient strong and independent we have
to let our children grow grow and
flourish by allowing them to figure some
things out on their own without constant
perfect
pruning so how do we strike that balance
between protecting and guiding without
overstepping into helicopter parenting
well Dr Lisa deore contends this begins
with providing a safe environment where
they can make mistakes and discover
their unique path on their own Lisa is a
Yale educated therapists with a
doctorate in Clinical Psychology from
the University of Michigan who
specializes in education and Child
Development she's the author of three
New York Times bestsellers untangled
under pressure and the emotional lives
of
teenagers here's Lisa on how we can
protect our kids while also allowing
them to build
resilience the way we view it in
Psychology is that distress is integral
to human functioning and for
teenagers and of course this is within
limits but for teenagers distress is
part of how actually all of us navigate
the world you know we we know what feels
good and what doesn't and so we do you
know more of the things that feel good
hopefully and less of the things that
you know are having negative
consequences and for teenagers it is
also growth giving it's actually
profoundly growth giving when I think
about the kids I worked with clinically
who have gone through something really
painful and I mean gone through it like
been allowed to have the experience and
find their way through I've never seen
maturation happen at so rapid a pace and
and what I mean you know there may be a
kid who you know is confronted by a
tragedy something really awful happens
and it's extremely painful and we would
wish that it never happened but if
they're helped through it you end up
with teenagers who are philosophical and
and broadminded in ways that you don't
see usually at that age or um if a
teenager messes up does something really
dumb right like cheats and gets caught
and has to sit with the consequences at
school and sit with the consequences at
home those are the kids who in my
practice are saying thing to me like I
never want to feel this way again like
I'm going to organize myself around not
having to feel this
or this has made me think so much about
the kind of person I want to be and so I
find myself as a psychologist right now
in some way is trying to do PR for
distress right like it has a hugely
important Place really in all of our
lives and then especially for teenagers
feeling it helps them grow helps them
navigate and then knowing that they can
find their way through developing skill
sets for managing it is actually what
allows them to function autonomously it
allows them to move away from us go to
places where they don't necessarily know
that it's going to go well because if
they they consider it they think well if
it go if I go there and it doesn't go
well I can handle that like I have it
within myself to manage
whereas you know to answer your question
kids who feel that they can only proceed
in circumstances where they know they
won't be
uncomfortable or they could be
guaranteed that it's going to go well
end up on these extraordinarily narrow
paths right because that very little of
life has sure so for me I really think
being able
to accept distress and work one's way
through it for teenagers in particular
it's the keys to the kingdom it is what
lets them move freely into the world and
I think that one of the hardest things
about raising a teenager is you actually
cannot guarantee your teenager safety
like there's nothing you can do to
guarantee that your teenager will not
find themselves in a position that's
truly dangerous MH that is so so scary I
can say that both as a parent and as a
psychologist who cares for kids but I
also know that fear is a terrible
position from which to
parent the best gift we can give our
kids especially our teenagers is to try
to be a steady presence you know for
them you know a failed test a you know
ruptured friendship feels disastrous
like that's how they experience emotions
and they come home to us and they lay it
in front of us and the best we gift we
can give them is to be very empathic and
very attentive to it but not to react at
that at their level much less above
it I want to underscore something Lisa
just said fear is a terrible position
from which to parent when we overly
focus on their protection it can lead
our kids to fear taking risks so the
goal is to make sure our kids are
confident decisionmakers ERS that they
know who they are and have the ability
to exercise agency and most importantly
that they have a safe calm presence they
can rely upon when things go Ary because
no matter what you do there's nothing
that will stop your kids from
experiencing distress and disappointment
but letting go of The reigns is so much
easier said than done especially when we
want to keep our kids safe and give them
a seamless path to success and happiness
despite a world-class education and
parents devoted to meeting my every need
I'm an example of someone who fumbled my
way into adulthood guilty of making
countless avoidable mistakes and
suffering far more than I needed to
because my parents in good faith to be
fair had pruned me into prioritizing
academic and athletic success over
understanding knowing and honoring
myself I simply was never taught how to
be a conscious adult I didn't have
healthy mentors for this outside the
Home Instead fear of failure was my fuel
approval was my drug and achievement was
confused with self-worth my inherent
value as a person and my entitlement to
love and acceptance the result was a
toxic brew that led me astray
and has taken Monumental efforts to heal
our kids like every other human being
that has walked this Earth will fail
they'll mess up they're going to make
mistakes but the key thing to remember
is this those mistakes will blossom into
invaluable learning
opportunities one of the most important
things we can do as parents is teach our
kids to embrace failure a perspective
that Echoes throughout the work of
Jessica Ley in educator and author of
The New York Times best-selling book
aptly titled the gift of
[Music]
failure in this one study there's this
woman who looked at autonomy supportive
parenting versus directive parenting and
parents who direct their kids and are
constantly telling them okay now do this
now do this and and giving them every
step along the way those kids are less
able to sit and be frustrated those kids
are less able to sort of wrestle with
Challenge and they're more way more
likely to give up before the task is
finished that's important because when
we start talking about competence as
opposed to confidence confidence is sort
of the the way we the way we want kids
to feel we want them to feel you know
like they're they're great they're
wonderful they're smart they're talented
we want them to have you know these
force fields of wonderfulness around
them um competence is so much more
important for learning though because
competence is about having tried
something one way had it mess up and
then they try it another way and you
know Having learned some tools from the
first time that didn't work and then
reacting positively and and trying to
move forward with new Solutions and kids
and that that's actually as a term it's
called desirable difficulties there was
a fantastic book called make it stick
where you can read all about that
desirable difficulties are one of the
most important teaching tools we have
not only because it teaches competence
but because it actually helps our brain
encode information
better and for longer periods of time
and more thoroughly into our uh
long-term memory so when I can't use
desirable difficulties because a kid in
my class is just incapable of handling
frustrations and is impatient and is
scared of making a mistake scared of
failing um that kid's less teachable
that kid is going to learn Less in my
classroom than a kid who can be
frustrated a kid who's willing to take
the challenge problems and not afraid of
looking quote unquote dumb for a minute
when they don't know the answer those
kids are way more teachable and and I
love teaching those
kids Embrace failure create a safe space
for kids to fall back on teach them to
take appropriate risks give them
responsibility and stop focusing on
perfect parenting these lessons are
powerful but of course by no means are
they easy
for further elaboration on Salient
parenting strategies to implement these
ideas I again encourage listening to the
full conversations with the experts
quoted so far and reading their
respective books all of which are linked
in the show notes on the episode page at
rich roll.com
now assuming agreement with the
Wildflower approach suggested by Julie
ligot heims I suspect exceptions come to
mind
there are certainly circumstances where
a more Hands-On approach is required
where a child or a teenager is just not
equipped to handle a situation on their
own be it due to the level of danger or
perhaps their lack of
maturity one such circumstance is the
hellscape of social
media today's parents are not only
navigating kids through their
adolescence which is difficult enough
but we're also now faced with the
seemingly impossible task of guiding
them safely through the Labyrinth of the
online World a scenario without
historical precedent in the history of
humankind the Health and Social
implications of which are only beginning
to be understood and something I admit
to struggling with myself and like so
many have struggled to help my teens
navigate so where do we begin to
understand these social media Giants and
what do we know concerning the effects
of social media on
teens but first a quick break for a word
from our
[Music]
partners so what do we know concerning
the effects of social media on teens
here's former product manager on the
Facebook civil misinformation team
Francis howan who in 2021 blew the
whistle on Facebook for prioritizing
their own profits over Public Safety and
putting young people's lives at
risk if your kid uses social media for
more than 3 hours a day they're at um
like double or triple the risk of gain
depression or anxiety the average kid in
the United States uses these products
for three and half hours a day MH 30% of
kids say they're on till midnight or
later most week nights most school
nights right so sleep deprivation for
those who have not like dug into
literature uh it puts kids at Big risks
of academic deficits which stays with
them for the rest of their life it puts
them at higher risk for mental health
issues not just depression and anxiety
but also things like bipolar or
schizophrenia uh increases the rates of
substance use uppers because they're
tired downers because they're depressed
and rates of death from accidents so
like not just Automotive accidents but
like all cause accident rates you now
Facebook could come out and say we
acknowledge what a large role be playing
kids lives we're going to start
publishing a very simple set of data
each week it's going to take us 15
minutes to do like once and after that
I'll just update over time and we're
going to say how many kids are online at
10 11 midnight 1 2 3 a.m. we're going to
do it every week if they were doing that
if they were really serious about these
problems you know it doesn't violate any
one's privacy but we'd be able to see
did those numbers move when they
launched those things and as long as
they refused to release even basic data
like we should consider all of these
moves
marketing we are running a national
experiment on our
children and I think if more people
thought about it that way and said you
know we're running a national experiment
on our kids like what say should the
public have in that experiment I think
we'd have very different conversations
yeah
these statistics are absolutely
terrifying to say the least and all
reason why in May of 2023 the Surgeon
General Dr V myy issued an advisory on
the effects social media use has on
youth mental health here's the Surgeon
General even though technically 13 is
the age at which many platforms say
people can start using them about 40% of
kids 8 through 12 are using social media
so those rules are not being enforced
adequately either so you're right I
think the concern is great here uh that
and this is one of the reasons I issued
this advisory is it was in response to a
question that parents kept asking me
which is are so is social media safe for
my kids and putting all this together
like my two most important takeaways
were number one we don't have enough
evidence to say it's in fact safe and
two there's in fact growing evidence
that it's harming many of our children
and that statistic is is one of those
data points and I think this is just for
me a cautionary tale also of how we have
to be thoughtful about how we Embrace
and integrate new technology into our
lives it's not that we should push away
technology look I'm a Believer in
technology I use technology I spent
seven years building a technology
company like I'm a Believer technology
but it's ultimately in how it's designed
and how we use it that ultimately
impacts um how it affects our lives and
I think particularly when it comes to
our kids um I think the I think you you
can judge a society by how well it cares
for and supports and protects its
children I think this is too important
for us to get distracted from um we
can't because every year for a child is
an extraordinarily important time of
development for them our kids's
childhood is happening right now we
can't say come back in 5 years and we'll
fix this got to do that because every
day um you know I we I'm getting stories
from parents who are telling me about
how their child was harmed how their
child was exposed to content that urged
them to take their own life or to harm
themselves uh how they were harassed
exposed to to racist remarks to misogyny
online um you hear this again and again
and again from parents who are saying
why is this happening why isn't someone
doing something about it why doesn't
someone have my back we will put the
entire burden of managing this new
rapidly evolving technology on the
shoulders of parents who never grew up
with
it that's not fair right or on young
people who don't have the brain power
skills to reut it's addictive lures
that's right and then what that
basically is is it's pitting the best
developers and program designers in the
world against parents and
kids that's not a fair fight and and
that's why we've got to have the backs
of kids and parents on this issue and
again I can't think of something that's
more important for us to address look
when it comes to mental health more
broadly we we've with kids you know I've
at length spoken about the importance of
us improving access to treatment we got
to do that we're investing more in the
last 2 years in that that's a good step
forward there's more to do there but if
all we did was focus on treatment and
didn't address these deeper root causes
like loneliness and isolation like
social media which are impacting the
mental health of Youth then we just
can't keep up with the demand you know
like a universities are compared to 10
years ago many of them have hired double
triple in some cases quadruple the
number of Mental Health Counselors and
they still can't keep up with demand so
we've got to get at the root causes of
some of this and this is why addressing
technology and loneliness are so
[Music]
critical what's even more terrifying is
that this technology is still in its
infancy once again here is Lisa deore on
the dangers of the algorithmic nature of
social media and what we can do to help
our kids and teens form healthier
relationships with everyone's favorite
appendage the phone
the thing that make made me nervous and
continues to make me very nervous about
social media is the algorithm driven
nature of what kids are presented and so
that anything a kid I think most people
know this but I think it's still worth
articulating actually anything a kid or
that we spends time looking at or
searches for or likes or comments on the
algorithms driving these um social media
platforms will pick that data up and
then present them more of that in the
aim of getting them to not be able to
look away and what I think about with
those algorithms are norms that
teenagers are very vulnerable to the
Norms in their environment and so when I
think back to the like the Eating
Disorders finding where we just saw so
many eating disorders in the
pandemic there's a pretty decent
consensus that probably what drove a lot
of that is that we have kids who are
home they have tons of time on their
hands they have tons of like energy to
do do something so they do a little
searching for Fitness or um weight
control or whatever the algorithms pick
this up and start flooding their feeds
with um imagery related to dieting or
advice on dieting and in the absence of
leaving the home doing other things
looking at other people this becomes the
norm and it no longer seems strange to
you know Ultra diet do things that are
actually really really
dangerous and so when I worry about
social media what I worry about is that
it can shift the norms for kids and
change what they think to be typical and
so I think first of all none of us
should have our phones in our rooms I
don't have my phone in my room and so
one thing a parent might do is to say
okay we're making a family-wide rule
like it's all coming out for all of us
and of course the teenager will be like
no no no no no and the parent might
consider saying look it's bad for our
sleep it's it's bad for your sleep sleep
is the glue that holds us together for
us to take it out of our room and not
ask you to do the same it'd be like we
got in the car and we put on our seat
bels but we don't ask you to put on
yours so you can make that case the
other thing to try and again I does that
work well I'm offering these humbly I'm
offering these because I actually it
means enough to me that I don't want to
just write it off yeah yeah I think the
other thing to try is to say let's just
do a two to three week experiment like
sometimes teen will agree to an
experiment like let's take it out of
your room for a couple weeks and here's
a clock radio to replace all of the
things that you feel that it does and
then see if after a couple weeks there's
not some agreement around this here's
the other thing teenagers like to know
the why and this is again back to the
detector like they like to know
the why here's the why we have data
showing that you do not actually get as
good as sleep in a room with technology
in it and the reason for this that the
researchers smise and I think this is
true is that we are all so pavlovian
pavlovian attached to our
devices that if they are present we are
deploying a degree of energy to not
engage with
them so personally I found it insanely
helpful for my sleep to keep my phone as
far away from me as possible in the
hours leading up to and including
bedtime but while my older kids have
come to appreciate this practice
themselves let's just say it's been more
than a struggle with our
teenagers compounding the degree of
difficulty is the fact that every year
new technology comes out more savvy than
ever at capturing and maintaining
attention and the fight to resist
becomes even
steeper for the best of us it's like
bringing a knife to a a gunfight for the
young developing mind it's game
over it's just not feasible or
necessarily advisable to raise a lite so
what else can we do as parents Educators
and mentors to raise kids to have a
healthy or at least a healthier
relationship with the digital world once
again here's the Surgeon
General I'll tell you honestly this is
hard these devices are so intuitive for
kids my daughter when she was in
preschool came home one day and asked uh
my wife and I if uh we could post a
picture uh on a social media platform
for her and we like what how do you even
know about this platform how do you like
know that picture should go like we were
flabbergast but her preschool classmates
were talking about posting pictures on
social media so we know we have to be
vigilant there and part of this for us
is about protecting time without device
so we for every we have a curated list
sort of set of videos that we uh will
allow them to watch in small doses from
time to time when we're on an airplane
for example or here and there um things
that have some some sort of educational
or cultural value to them things that
don't have harmful content in them um so
we try to limit how much time they spend
there but we also know as they get older
that we have made the decision that we
want to delay their use of social media
until they're well pasted middle school
and potentially beyond that that's not
easy to do it's incredibly hard um but
one thing we know is that it'll be
easier if we can do it with other
parents and this is something that I've
now heard more and more from parents of
kids who have older kids is that this is
really tough to do on their own but when
they find one parent two parents who are
willing to make the same decision for
their child whether that's delaying the
use of social media or whether that's
drawing Tech creating tech-free zones
their child's life like not using social
media technology in the half hour before
they go to bed and throughout the night
or around meal times it becomes a lot
easier when you're doing this with other
parents it's still not not simple uh
because over the years I think largely
this technology has spread like wildfire
without any uh real guard rails uh you
know to limit children's use and and to
to healthy use and so what you're seeing
is that it's become this expectation uh
that every child is on it in some cases
schools are even assigning homework that
requires a use of devices and some cases
of some social media platforms so we
have to to pull back a bit and get to a
place where we can have Tech free zones
where parents can work together and
support one another uh in delaying use
um and I I think when we're planning to
do that until one we feel that our child
is actually developmentally ready to use
social media and two until real
safeguards have been put in place and I
mean specifically safety standards like
what we did for automobiles uh that we
are now calling for in our advisories to
be applied to social media and until
there's data that actually tells us that
these platforms are in fact sufficiently
safe for our kids like we don't let our
kids take medicines that aren't studied
uh to be safe and effective we don't put
them in car seats that haven't been
certified to be safe yet we're having
them use these platforms which are
profoundly changing how they see
themselves and others with scaned data
uh to reassure us at all about
safety yeah it's uh it's a huge problem
I'll be interested to see how that
progresses for you as they age it's
almost like an Astic curve like with
with every year uh you know the pressure
um to get the device to be online in
that way increases exponentially um and
it's a hard problem because on some
level fluency on those platforms is a
gateway or kind of um a key to having a
social life right if you you can't be a
lite you would be a social Pariah among
your peers and your classmates as a
young person um who's on the outside
it's sort of like the kid who doesn't K
get picked for the Kickball team is the
kid who's not part of the Snapchat group
chat or whatever it is right so that
complicates it from a parenting point of
view can I just say that two interesting
things that i' I've learned recently one
is that as I've talked to more and more
students like middle school and high
school students who are actually
building movements to actually get off
social media and get on uh
offline they often have in the beginning
when their parents told them hey you
can't use this until later they fought
it and they were angry but over time
they actually came to feel a lot better
because they saw themselves less subject
to a lot of the anxieties and struggles
that their peers were going through as
they you know engage with bullying or
harassment online or constant comparison
with other people but the other thing is
as that community grows and builds those
kids aren't alone right and there are
more parents I also encounter who are
looking for what we used to term dumb
phones right phones that don't have the
capability of having social media but
have the ability to text uh to look up
to make phone calls to use maps so good
for safety good for communication with
friends but don't necessarily subject
you to all of the other potential
adverse effects of social media so I
think there are additional Pathways that
we have to build here but you're
absolutely right that it's not simple
and and there's a transition challenge
here which is why I think it's so
important that we do this together with
the support of other parents I know my
wife and I can't do this alone if we
left up to us alone we'd probably fail
at some point and we also I think for
adolesence in particular just have to
recognize that they're not just younger
adults they're fundamentally at a
different stage of brain development
where they and Social Development where
they are more prone than adults to
social comparison and to social
influence and so you put all of this
together and you recognize that what
these a lot of students are telling
Educators is true which is that they may
see the challenge but in some cases they
need a little help and support in
creating the environment where they and
the opportunity for them to actually
separate and when they do and experience
that a lot of times they want to build
on it just like the 20-year-olds that
you're talking about uh and that's think
that's part of the reason why we're
seeing more communities of kids coming
together to say hold on we're we're
tired of this we want a different path
that's not to say we're estwing
technology and putting it at the side we
want to use technology responsibly but
we don't want it to rule Our
Lives
ideally delay a child's immersion into
social media for as long as possible and
when kids finally are granted access to
devices it's incumbent upon us to
immediately set clear ground rules like
for example initially limiting their
functionality to basic communication
like texting and then and this is really
important following through by actually
enforcing those rules something I admit
to having been less than Stellar about
if your child already has a device or
social media of any kind the first real
step in helping them navigate that
responsibility safely is awareness and
communication the more you understand
what kind of content they're being
exposed to consuming and curating the
better your ability to initiate informed
conversations to create open
communication and maintain it requires a
suspension of that impulse we all have
to approach transgressions punitively
instead what we have to do is lead with
curiosity because young ones teens in
particular simply are not going to open
up if they feel judged or Worse unsafe
as parents we should aim to guide our
children in developing discernment a
critical eye towards not just social
media content but towards every
situation they will face in life
with social media in particular that
means teaching them to discern carefully
crafted digital images from reality and
understanding the potential implications
of constant
connectivity it's less about protecting
our kids from the online world and much
more about teaching them how to navigate
it responsibly and safely because again
the digital age is here to stay a
accomplishing this of course always goes
back to creating a safe environment
conducive to open communication if your
kid is shut down it's probably because
you have created consciously or
otherwise an environment that doesn't
feel safe and it's incumbent upon you
not your kid to change that but even in
the best case scenario the truth is that
all we can do is give them the tools
they need and then and this is the
really hard part we need to trust
them sit tight we have a lot more great
stuff on the way but first a quick break
for a word from our
partners when my eldest daughter turned
13 suddenly everything I did irritated
her no matter what I said whether was
something that mirrored her budding
personality or something that diverged
from it absolutely everything annoyed
her as parents who adore their kids and
remember how sweet they were when they
were small moments like these can be
quite painful they can be gut-wrenching
even and I think we all understand that
individuation is a healthy and necessary
aspect of growing up and yet it still
does feel personal even when you know
that it isn't and so the challenge the
Jedi approach to coin my wife's metaphor
is Extreme
neutrality to depersonalize everything
and not allow any of this to impact your
emotional state of being so that you're
not reactive in these situations and
instead totally
aanus but change is in ently stressful
and no change is more pronounced than
the transformation from childhood to
adolescence so where do we start in
better understanding this crazy roller
coaster ride interestingly psychologists
Mark the beginning of adolescence much
earlier than we might suspect at age 11
the onset of puberty brings significant
changes both visible and internal
impacting the brain's functioning and
leading to a redistribution of power to
the emotional centers as a result that
sweet child who reliably laughed at your
jokes and loved your company May
suddenly seem distant and
moody this unfortunately is not only
normal it's
necessary adolescence is a time of
individuation it's a healthy part of
growing up we all experienced it and
despite the painful moments that this
stage can bring it's important for us as
parents to detach ourselves emotionally
from what's Happening and understand
that our teens behavior isn't a personal
attack but trust me achieving this level
of Detachment is not easy if you can
manage it even 20% of the time you're
doing exceptionally well with this in
mind I want to share a powerful
perspective shift courtesy of teen
Whisperer and behavioral expert Josh
ship while a kid is trying to become a
teen and get that Independence you know
they begin to push away the parent and
the way I always think about this is is
kind of like a roller
coaster meaning you know when you get in
the roller coaster seat they put like
the lap bar down in your in your lap and
if you're like me kind of grab that bar
and like wiggle the crap out of it see
if it's actually locked in yeah I'm just
I'm a little OCD in general but also
like all right I want to make sure like
you know this is safe and this is secure
and I and I wiggle it and I push it and
I Pro it not not hoping it will give
leading to my inevitable death but I
push it and I Pro it and I test it
hoping it will
hold and kids who are going into the
teen years are going to do the exact
same thing to you mhm and they're not
pushing and prodding and
testing hoping that you will give but
rather hoping that you will hold you
know hoping that at this time in their
life when so many things are uncertain
and so many things are
unsure that you're certain and that
you're
[Music]
sure there's no denying that parenting
is a demanding job and as many parents
can attest the teen years can present
some let's just call them unique
challenges so how do we maintain a
meaningful connection with our teenagers
especially when they start to withdraw
emotionally a powerful Mantra that I
have relied upon and that has comforted
me more times than I can count is this
it's your job to love your kids but it's
not your kids's job to love
you this cannot be overemphasized so let
me say it again it's your job to love
your kids but it's not your kids' job to
love
you do not look to your kids to meet
your emotional needs it's simply not
their responsibility to make you feel
okay
period I want you to think long and hard
about if and when you have done this in
the past Journal those occasions develop
in awareness of what triggers that
impulse catch yourself when you find
yourself doing it and stop
it in terms of creating and maintaining
open
communication focus on asking questions
rather than
lecturing lecturing leads to tuning out
questions on the other hand promote
critical thinking and they open a window
into your teens perspectives and beliefs
instead of imposing your views on them
encourage them to express their own
thoughts and develop their own
viewpoints for example instead of
telling them what they did wrong and
what they should have done this is every
parents impulse instead replace that
impulse with these three
words tell me more tell me more you may
not like the answers they give
but I got to tell you it's a lot better
to know what they think than to be kept
in the
dark it's essential to remember that as
your child grows up your role shifts it
shifts from control to influence by
asking questions and fostering an
environment of open communication you
not only build trust you help your
teenager to think critically and make
wise decisions
independently skills that will serve
them well throughout their
life once again this is Josh
ship think of yourself as a coach um and
think about what a good coach does coach
prepares the athletes before the game
let's run drills let's go through
scenarios what's that you're being
bullied at school emotionally you know
some kids being a you know jerked to you
verbally let's go through that you know
let's talk about how you're currently
responding hm do you think that kind of
perpetuates the situation do you think
getting a rise out of that like they
like to see you snap or cry or yell or
whatever like let's go through the
different scenarios you're going to be
in just like a coach does before the
game let's run the drills let's go
through the stuff great job here you
know watch that that's there's the thing
that's going to get you mhm um after the
game the coach great job on this let's
work on this let's review here's what
went well here's what didn't but during
the game it's all on them you know we
can't step on the court right
that that's not how it works and I think
that's really the game when we talk
about influence versus control that's
what it looks like to have a teen is it
is that you're not out there on the
court you're not out there on the field
you don't sadly have control um but you
have influence which means even if you
can't control in that moment because
you're not there or they're at school or
they're out with friends or they're out
God knows where you do have that
influence before and after to try to
train them to execute
appropriately during the teen years by
far the single most powerful force for
adolescent mental health is a strong
relationship with caring adults but it's
not just about caring it's about knowing
how to channel that care in a way that
resonates with them it's about meeting
them more than halfway not constantly
imposing our expectations or judgments
on them guilt and fear don't make us
better parents but you know what does
understanding patience and of course
love especially when it comes to
discipline by far one of the most
challenging aspects of
parenting to further complicate matters
our children's actions often draw the
watchful judgmental eyes of the public
we're scrutinized our parenting Styles
dissected and our actions CRI SE the
fear of disapproval coupled with our own
confusion often paralyzes us leaving us
feeling helpless and
stressed KJ Del anonia a former New York
Times Reporter and author who has
dedicated her career to studying and
understanding family Dynamics is quite
wise when it comes to navigating the
turbulence of
discipline so one of the pieces of
research that I did myself was to work
with a professor at forom University and
we created um an academically
peer-reviewed appropriate uh I would
call it a survey but I think there's a
better word for it um study in which we
got a thousand people who were you know
demographically reflective of the United
States not a thousand of my closest
Facebook friends to respond to questions
around um happiness and parenting and we
use the academic measure for for
happiness which is uh satisfact it's
like uh how how how it's called efficacy
and it's how how good do you think you
are at this thing and so one of the
things we had on there as well as lots
of you know questions about well how do
you decide what your kids have to eat
and how do you feel about how much
homework they have and how do you feel
about your involvement we had this
open-ended question we actually had two
and one was what do you like most and
the other one was what do you like least
and you could just write so many people
responded with some variation of the
word discipline then I went back and
read through our survey to make sure we
weren't secretly queuing them like did
we use the word discipline 46 times or
something there was nothing you know I
couldn't find anything like a third
about a third of the
answers accumulated around this idea of
I hate disciplining my kids I hate
making my kids follow the rules I hate
it when my kids do something wrong and I
have to punish them I hate having to
come up with consequences like there was
this real consensus that that was the
thing and I really think that if you had
surveyed our parents they would not have
said that I don't know what they would
have said but I don't think it would
have been that so that was really
interesting it didn't bother them to
discipline no right so what do you make
of that I mean what does that mean well
my my theory um is that one of the
things that's hard is that we are
expected to have disciplined kids who
behave in public spaces and you know act
like disciplined kids but there's no
consensus anymore on how we're supposed
to get there like when um when our
parents were parenting and when we were
being raised there was this more
authoritative culture um authoritarian
culture where the idea was if your child
does yeah if your child does something
wrong there is a consequence and that
will teach your child not to do the
wrong thing and whether actually that
didn't necessarily work and it's got its
problems but it was a thing like there
was an expectation so when your child
didn't do the right thing you knew what
you were going to do um you know you
were going to ground them or you were
going to take away the television or you
were going to you know not let them go
to the dance you you knew but now we
don't really have an agreement around
that now it's sort of well you know do
you have a conversation with them is
this a learning experience do you try to
um you know do you try to talk to them
what works for your kid and that's
actually I mean it's a better space but
it's confusing no social consensus It's
upsetting and if you if you well um I
have a kid who's who's tough and who has
emotional challenges and one of of the
things that we discovered for her with
is the consequences just completely
backfired so we would be in a public
space and this child would do something
you know horrific that would cause
everyone else to sort of turn and stare
waiting for you to impose some form of
of you know terrible consequence you
know and and would observe us sort of
just standing there and watching
the and you you it feels terrible you
know everyone around you expecting sort
of waiting for you to do something and
you knowing that that something that
they that that your best choice is to
ride this out but maybe it's the right
thing for you so anyway I think that
makes that lack of a consensus around
what we are supposed to do and what
we're expected to do and what the people
around us will approve of our doing
makes that a really stressful yeah so we
second guess every move that we make and
yeah you know we just don't have an
answer as KJ alluded to it's important
to remember that there's no one size
fits-all solution what works for one
child might not work for another this
has been the case in my own personal
experience the usual consequences of bad
behavior backfired with our most
emotional and strong willed child took
some time but I realized that the best
course of action with this person was to
Simply ride it out to let the storm pass
and talk about it with them later when
we both weren't emotionally charged the
ability to pause in these tough moments
takes superhuman amounts of patience I
try to constantly remind myself that
these tough moments aren't the end of
the world because let's be honest the
ultimate goal isn't to raise perfectly
disciplined children it's to Foster
emotional resilience to equip them with
the tools they need to face the world
with
confidence once again let's hear from
Teen Whisperer Josh
ship to parent a teen well you need to
do two things consistent encouragement
and consistent
consequences at the end of the day if
you can do both of those things
consistently your kids's going to be
fine not perfect not without issue not
without you know fault or flaw or
whatever they're still going to be human
but for the most part you will have an
independent responsible caring young
person on your hands at the end of that
uh and with most parents that I see uh
that I've worked with they tend to air
on being really really good at one or
the other but not so much both MH so uh
you know sometimes we can be in the
media in such very harsh on parents that
sort of coddle their kids and we could
say oh you're raising entitled kids and
don't you realize what you're doing but
that so often comes from a good place of
like they want to be encouraging and May
maybe they weren't encouraged as a child
and it was like a very sort of insanely
strict like home with with with all
tough and no tender and so they're like
well I'm not going to make that mistake
they're compensating in the other
direction yeah and so you know there has
to be that encouragement but there also
has to be consistent
consequences um and and the consequences
side can sometimes be the thing that's
tricky because uh to really do it well
the consequences need to be
premeditated
predetermined the entire family needs to
be on the same page not at not at the
time of War but the time before War like
meaning before because once you're in
the war it's you're reactive and you're
impulsive and emotional and suddenly
you're saying things that you didn't
sort of plan out ahead of time and that
creates inconsistencies right you flip
in or you flip out you know depending on
your personality type like you either
snap and the punishment is too harsh or
you say things you look back at and go
ah that was so stupid I wish I wouldn't
have said that that could cause some
kind of pain or whatever or you flip in
cuz you know you're not sure what to do
you're exhausted from from your day the
stuff going on in your own life you
don't have a game plan ahead of time so
you just flip in and you go yeah it's
not a big deal or it's not something I
really need to worry
about if you're feeling overwhelmed by
the prospect of disciplining your
children you're not alone every parent
grapples with this challenge they second
guess their decisions and sometimes it
just feels like we're failing and
failing and failing again here's Lisa
deora's
take so when we look at the research and
when we distill all of it on like what
kids need at home it's two things they
need warmth and they need need structure
so I think you can actually bring both
so say a kid does something really that
they should not have done you can have
the structure of saying all right that
comes with consequences right you you
know it's a breach of trust we got to be
able to trust you to let you go out and
about so you will be hanging out with us
for the next couple of weekends and then
the worms can come and be like what
happened like that's so not like you
like it's not an either or um right and
and I would just say you know if parents
are like where am I supposed to be in
all of this if they just keep going back
to that idea you want to be warm they
want to you want to feel you you want
your kids to feel that you both them and
also actually like them and you want to
have structure that there should be a
predictability to family life that the
rules should make sense that the rules
should be enforced the kids are going to
know what's going to happen and kids do
like rules teenagers do like rules they
don't like Lucy goosey adults um I think
all the time about moments in my
practice where a teenager would float in
front of me something like um oh you
know we were over at Susie's house and
Susie's mom will buy for us and they put
it out in this way like you know and I
would go really and they go I know it's
so weird I don't know why she does that
and and I've learned that they'll often
um present something kind of neutrally
to like check to see how you
respond and even when they've seemed to
be neutral to like positive about it if
I've stayed with my gut and been like
what they're like thank you right
they're so glad here's the thing about
teenagers they are like so able to
detect dishonesty and hypocrisy like so
much better than at any point in life
like better than kids better than
adults and they really really respect
honesty like they really respect it and
so sometimes if I'm doing an intake with
a kid who's in my office because they've
gotten themselves in trouble with
drinking or something like that I will
say are you worried about your drinking
like that's usually how I'll start by
asking
and sometimes kids will say actually yes
you know and then we're off to one
conversation and sometimes they'll
say no or I don't know and I will say I
don't know yet how I feel about your
drinking I'm just going to keep you
posted but based on what you're telling
me I'm not so sure that this is working
for you or that this is safe what you're
describing and I I'm Amazed by how
accepting they are of that like they
would so much rather you play your cards
face up even if they don't like your
cards MH then have it seem like you're
bluffing
M it's okay to accept that you won't
always have the answers and I want you
to really hear that it is okay to be
uncertain use these moments as learning
experiences for both you and your
children as difficult as it is don't let
societal expectations dictate your
parenting Style again each child is
unique and requires is a unique approach
so don't feel pressured to conform to
the norm and whatever happens remember
it's not the end of the world our
children's mistakes aren't
life-threatening they're learning
experiences that will help them grow
into resilient confident
individuals and finally remember the
importance of self-care because at the
end of the day if you're not taking care
of yourself and your own personal needs
it's really going to be exceptionally
harder for to care for your child and
their
[Music]
needs unfortunately our society often
commends the sacrificial parent it's as
if we're socially wired to believe that
a good parent is one who relentlessly
sacrifices for their children often to
their own detriment while we are
hardwired to prioritize our children's
needs over our own this selflessness
often leaves us drained leaves us
unfulfilled or Worse blaming our
children for our own unmet
needs now it may feel selfish or
indulgent to even consider ourselves
when there are lunches to pack homework
to help with and endless loads of
laundry to do but in reality our
well-being directly impacts our ability
to parent effectively our ability to
communicate well and to maintain that
all too important equinity in thei face
of stress and conflict yet even as we
discuss this I couldn't help but notice
a twinge of guilt creeping in because
after all isn't it almost sacriligious
to even consider our own happiness in
the face of our children's needs isn't
our role as parents to bear that brunt
of sacrifice and selflessness for their
sake well KJ D anonia has a few thoughts
on
this it's actually much better for them
um to see the adults in their lives
having a a productive happy Pleasant uh
joyful experience otherwise how are they
going to learn to do that but this is
like this is our time right we've got 20
plus years of raising our families and
being with them and being all together
in that same house and and sort of
having this experience of being a family
I just want us to make it great for
everybody so one of my mantras is that
you can be happy when your kids are not
and that definitely makes some people
kind of go who yeah makes people nervous
little you know little step back there
wait no I can't I can only be as happy
as my unhappiest kid right that's the
saying I can't be happy when they're not
but um you know let's sort of let's
let's talk this let's let's parse this
out so if you're the kid and things are
going wrong for you you know like you
didn't get invited to the birthday party
and you're 11 and your mom is losing her
mind cuz you didn't get invited to the
birthday party a couple of things are
happening first of all you're like whoa
maybe this is a big deal I mean I was
thinking it was an 11-year-old birthday
party but maybe it's huge secondly our
kids don't actually want us to be
unhappy I mean all right sometimes it
feels like they do especially at 2:00 in
the morning or whatever but they really
don't uh so here's your child going when
I tell my mom that things like that
happen she gets really upset maybe I
shouldn't tell her or oh my dad got
really you know like when I didn't make
the team it really freaked him out so
maybe like maybe I should maybe I should
either pretend it doesn't matter to me
or not try out because like I don't like
to upset my parents so those are some
unintentional consequences that they are
feeling plus um you know our kids don't
need the burden of our happiness on top
of theirs because we you know we are we
are
worthy of putting time into ourselves
and making our own decisions about like
sort of how we want to spend Saturday
and where we want to go for vacation and
even what we want to have for dinner it
doesn't have to revolve around somebody
else you know whether that's your kids
or your parents or or or any or I'm
sorry your parents your partner um or
anything I it's just I feel like um you
know I talked to this this great expert
Rick Hansen you probably know him um
he's the neur psychologist he's the
author of um hardwired for happiness and
he's written a lot about how you know
human brains are really kind of they're
wired to look for the bad stuff right
because bad stuff is dangerous and we
got to look for those Tigers we got to
remember where the tigers are um and
he's his idea is that the more time we
spend soaking in like the good stuff the
more we can train our brains not to
freak out about imaginary Tigers cuz
there aren't that many but the point the
reason I'm sort of telling that story is
that at some point he said to me you
know sometimes I feel like Americans are
afraid to be happy and that really
soaked in for me like I don't want to be
afraid to be happy I want to I want to I
want to go for it I want to like grab
all the happy that I can and that
doesn't mean you know everybody else out
of my way I'm going to get my own happy
it it means um uh you know let's let's
build something that that's wonderful
for all of
us ultimately being a happier parent is
all about our mindset it's about how we
choose to look at our experiences how we
interact with our kids and what we
choose to pay attention
to we can make a conscious decision to
focus on the moments of joy and
happiness even in the mundane routines
of daily life as KJ apply put it a
significant part of being happier is
about choosing to pay attention to the
things that bring us happiness
being a parent isn't about achieving
Perfection it's about nurturing our
children it's about guiding them through
life's challenges and most importantly
being happy after all happiness isn't
just the
destination it truly is the journey
whether you're a parent a guardian a
teacher or simply someone who interacts
with children on a daily basis your
happiness influences those around you
kids pick up on our moods and our
emotions often mirroring them if we
radiate joy and positivity they are
likely to do the same it is in this vein
the parenting offers a huge Challenge
and a gift it pushes us to be the best
most authentic version of ourselves more
than any other experience in life we
have a duty to lead by exist example and
to be mindful about the messages we
convey and the values we
embody it's about proving that it's
possible to live a fulfilling successful
and happy life while also staying true
to who you are and what you believe in
because in the end the most powerful
message we can impart to our children is
The Importance of Being
[Music]
Yourself
today's master class was packed with a
battery of resources and my hope is that
they serve you on your parenting Journey
while I can't offer you a prescription
for parenting I hope this primer has
given you some perspective on how to
parent more consciously a reminder that
links to the the full episodes for each
of the individuals excerpted today can
be found in the show notes at Rich
roll.com and if you want to check out
our past masterclass episodes those too
are linked in this episode show notes
and available at rich roll.com or your
favorite streaming platform thank you
for spending this time with me and my
guests I hope you found it both helpful
and instructive until next time Peace
Love namaste